Ça t'arrive de pas bander ?
Ouais ? En ce moment par exemple j'suis pas euh...
Tu vois, hier j'ai ramené un mec chez moi...
Donc euh, on se chauffe.. On se pêcho tout ça
Mais une fois dans le lit, il arrivait plus à bander.
Du coup normal, je le branle, tu vois...
Généreux !
-Merci, mais, ça marchait pas.
Ça a duré .. J'sais pas, un quart d'heure vingt minutes facile.
M'ouais, un peu long.
Il avait mis de la musique on s'est tapés genre quatre  chansons des Red Hot et deux pubs Deezer..
Quatre chansons des Red Hot et deux pubs Deezer et ... Rien ?...
Bah en fait j'avais toujours l'impression que ça allait démarrer parce qu'il avait une sorte de quart de molle
Une petite étincelle de trique, mais ça démarrait pas.
Un peu comme toi et ton barbecue tiens ...
Attention, le barbecue va démarrer !
Mais alors le pire, c'est quand il a essayé de mettre une capote, alors que clairement, il était pas ...
Ouais... On a tendance à faire ça..
Et des fois ça marche ?
Hm... Non.
Pourquoi vous tentez, alors si ça marche pas ?
Le geste, le challenge, on veut être les premiers à accomplir quelque chose..
Pourquoi tu crois qu'on a escaladé le Kilimandjaro ?
Pourquoi tu crois qu'on a fait du dos crawlé jusqu'à l'Angleterre ?
Parce qu'on veut être des héros de la vie de tous les jours...
Moi je veux être le premier à réussir ça, et sortir dans la rue,
le monde s'arrête, ils laissent tomber leurs cafés et là ils font...
AHHH C'EST LUI !
L'homme qui a réussi a mettre une capote alors qu'il bandait pas de ouf !
Ohhh comment il a fait? comment il a fait ?
On sait pas, personne ne sait, mais c'est pour ça que tu portes son prénom.
C'est beau.
Certes, mais hier c'était juste triste, tu mettais deux nains a côté de lui on aurait dit une épreuve de fort Boyard.
Et t'as essayé, de j'sais pas... De lui donner un coup de main ?
Bah oui, oui j'lui ai donné un coup de main, j't'ai dit, j'ai fait que ça pendant 20 minutes !
Non, non mais un coup de main avec la bouche.
J'suis pas spécialement une romantique, j'demande pas des pétales de roses, des bougies tout ça.
Mais dans ma bouche, une teub molle luisante de liquide séminal hmm, c'est pas mon gros kiff non plus quoi.
De t'façon, ça marche jamais vraiment, ça aide pas.
Tu fais quoi toi, quand t'arrives pas à bander ?
Moi non plus j'suis pas un grand romantique, mais j'ai des techniques.
Je ferme les yeux...
J'respire... Je pense a des choses apaisantes, agréables, excitantes ...
Et si ça fonctionne pas ben,
je presse la base je rentre le pouce, je rentre, je sors le pouce, je me met en étau et je frétille comme ça : haut haut bas bas gauche droite gauche droite.
Normalement ça passe.
Et tu fais ça jusqu'à ce qu'elle s'endorme, j'imagine.
Non non une chanson des Red Hot plus ou moins
Apres c'est bon ?
Ouais, bon en même temps, quand je commence à durcir je sais que je vais jouir directement donc bon hein ...
Et en fait ça va le mec d'hier
Le pire coup de l'univers c'est toi.
Au lieu de te moquer, viens donc aider le pire coup de l'univers à allumer le barbecue... Je galère
Ah ! Je...
Ta geule, ferme bien ta geule.
Essaies de cracher dessus
Arrête !